hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play the
Kerbal space program okay you guys asked
for more in here I am sorry for the
delay on the video today because I have
been trying oh so hard to get the
slender the arrival easter egg glitch
level whatever you want to call it to
work for three hours I'm not even joking
I tried every single permutation every
single like configuration like
flashlight radio first radio flashlight
first we're going out the garage door
doing it over and over again I've tried
everything and I could not get it to
work I was so frustrated that I just
gave up after three hours of recording
straight I gave up there's nothing to
show for it it's boring
so we are gonna take our frustration out
on these poor unsuspecting kerbals hah
hah hah hah hah hah okay so I'm gonna
approach this a bit more scientifically
basically I'm gonna try to actually get
into space the moon is the next step but
space is the first step because we we
have yet to break the atmosphere so what
we need is obviously more fuel and less
weight or more thrust all in general so
what we need to do is we need to get a
lightweight cockpit this one looks good
it has a total mass of one this one
that's pointed but this one seems like
it might be a bit more reliable and it
looks cooler anyway so as you can see we
need to create a sort of fuel system
that is both aerodynamically stable and
symmetrical as well as being really
really awesome so first off let's put a
nose cone on this piace okay so we need
a linear that's a thruster that's not a
nose cone this is a nose cone so oh
that's tiny where's the nose cone uh aha
here we go this is more like it
gaaaah oh that even matches that's cool
and then we put this on top haha my
device is almost Kemp was not even near
complete so I shouldn't say that but it
needs an sis module someone told me that
I needed to be able to actually let me
put the SAS model module in between so
that it's got some stability yeah
perfect ok now we need a good you need a
good ratio of fuel true weight and then
ample thrust so I want the center one to
be the maximum thrust but at the same
time I want the other ones to be the
primary ignition like the short burst
low fuel ones that break off how I do
that I have no clue but whatever I'm not
a rocket scientist ok this one seems
like it's got a lot of fuel but it's got
more mass so let's go with this one it's
not as heavy it seems like it's a good
deal
ok we'll go with that and I'm thinking
like I'm pretty sure you need some sort
of like there's a bunch of oxidizers and
and who's ooh what's its and Winkley
wonk ease and other stuff like that so I
need a big thruster ok wait hang on let
me read this yeah I got enough ok so you
got that and this is looking really bad
but I don't care it's not exactly
aerodynamic but then again it don't need
to be whoo whoo whoo whoo okay let's
create another one and apparently it's
bad ass backwards so
oh god what is that that thing's huge
good lordy no thank you
valid well I guess that for getting
really heavy stuff into space but I
don't even think this is gonna get me
all the way into space but I'm not here
to argue about that I'm just here to to
make things explode frankly so I don't
really care about all of that
let's try this one looks like a yeah
that looks about right okay so these
people are gonna die let me actually
angle snap this yep that looks better
and right there alright so now I need
some nice cheap thrusters through those
bad boys butter ski brings that up a bit
that's looking like a spaceship ain't it
ah right aerodynamics is 'm DeltaWing
provide high life and stable scent of a
center of gravity for everyday rules are
big too bad bigger than I need but ah
sighs Wow maybe I should do something
small is this smaller that's more like
it that's better that's better okay
that's looking more like it I like it
already
I need to move these to number one and
wait no that's backwards should be in
zero no I'm gonna assume that's correct
cuz it was like it was the other way
okay center of thrust looking good
center of lift looking good
center of mass right on the money right
on the center of lift oh yeah it's
looking good that Lots is bad boy into
space cattle cattle cattle gabon cat out
let's go alright who do we got Bob well
you must know what happened to Bill in
jebediah jeopardise still somewhere up
in the atmosphere not to burn up but uh
are we ready to lift off our throttling
up a look Bob's all excited Oh
ignition in ten nine one I need to make
very very very steady adjustments on
this very small oh lordy no no go the
other way how do I make you go the other
way sobbing go the other way there we go
there we go little bit better a little
bit better a little bit better no no no
no get back here
get back here now stop it what are you
doing Bob control your ship these
controls don't make any sense why now
and you you switch on me you're
switching the controls on me the
gyroscope is not helping how do I
activate the SAS okay SCS has been
activated where the hell are we going
holy crap SAS help me out here okay
primary fuel is almost over and now the
second stage should fire any minute now
stage switch stage how do I switch the
stage switch the damn stage switch the
damn stage there we go okay
all right the stage has been switched
Bob looks concerned hey Bob how are you
doing they're on the bottom left how are
you doing how are you doing there hi Bob
I'm Bob don't be worried I'm I have a
bad feeling that this rocket is not
doing nearly enough thrust and we're not
even going up anymore so uh it's hold on
there Bob turn off SAS and get some no
not that way now turn back on
I should add SAS back on from the
beginning turn it off turn it on I don't
know Bob I don't know we're going up
we're going down I'm trying to get it
back into normal up but it's not
cooperating why are you going that way I
bow I'm beheading I'm not this is bad as
bad as bad this bad this bad no no I
killed Bob ha ha ha why does it suck so
much
Oh Oh Bob curvin is killed oh well
alright let's go back to the drawing
board here obviously the center one is
not nearly enough lift apparently it
needs much mucho more lift oh let's get
a different symmetry mode going here for
the primary engines let's take this out
of here cuz that didn't work at all that
SAS module is she okay
so this one is chock full of jet fuel
see here these are small they're liquid
fuel but they also these also have
oxidized alright you know what screw it
let's go for size over quality Oh God
actually let's not do that let's um just
put a fuel tank there and now we put
these on the sides I think it won't even
fit oh my god yes it will
oh my god no no holy crap no oh my god
it actually works no this is
bad idea but I want to do it let's get
some you know stability aerodynamics now
I can use these big ones I feel so bad
for the next person to go in here let's
do it oh my god
minton minton Kerman
I'm so sorry Minton throttle up SAS on
power no make the fuel tanks collided
into each other structural fairly on
liquids between Rocco Max and fuel tank
and Rocco vertical tank Oh God
okay take that out of there okay who's
this this couldn't hold this couldn't
handle all of the all of the power let's
try that again but uh with less failure
okay let's try smaller outside engines
well we're gonna have a lot of thrust
this time oh my god that was so damn
funny that was so damn funny and I know
it shouldn't be because it was really
sad or something but whatever it was to
me that was so damn funny okay we're
gonna try to keep the center of thrust
relatively even all right
aerodynamics is get these nice and
actually those puppies on the inside now
the outside on the inside inside outside
outside
yeah it looks good
wait no I don't want those I want I want
I don't want finsihed yeah these are
yeah that's what I like I think I'm not
sure those don't even go on there okay
nevermind standard whatever just do it
it's gonna blow up anyway I don't even
know why I'm bothering to try let's do
it
hi Raisa del roof all right SAS bands
are Kerman don't mind what happened to
the last guys yes a s module is on okay
all right all right here we go look
pretty good that's pretty good doing
pretty good I'm hoping that the SAS
module to keep you relatively stable
steady it seems to be doing pretty good
so
don't look so scared dancer you're doing
better than wire they wobbling why are
they wobbling what like why are they
wobbling dancer you should be scared
when things wobble that's bad
I guess we're okay relatively that is
not a good thing now the engines are
starting to wobble and slugs so no we're
running out of fuel Oh No
what are we gonna do okay the wobbling
is settling feel gone looking good right
how we in space
Oh in space yet I don't think we are I
would be very scared mr. Kermit because
we seem to be losing altitude very
quickly what happened to the fuel on the
center fuel tank did I need to link
those up somehow with like other stuff I
don't know
time to go out grab on he made it hahaha
grab okay he's grabbing on boom doomed
okay alright he's falling now abort
abort the mission abort little bunny oh
boy don't let go don't let go
oh thanks seem to be tilting okay I'm
gonna I'm gonna doom to a fate worse
than death as you're gonna go out and
now he's falling Felix fir'd Birkin berg
whatever the guy did the Red Bull guy
that fell out of this guy oh damn funny
he's got this sombre look of acceptance
on his snow he's screaming no he's
pretty upset he looks pretty upset I
shouldn't find this as funny as I do but
it's just for some reason this is so
mean
but after what I went through trying to
get slender the arrival these dragon
work
alright let's not let's let's not watch
this it's just in the flight yeah let's
let's not do that let's not do that okay
we're gonna go we're gonna get this
sumbitch in space these wings they just
get in the way all right you know what
I'm tired of messing around here we're
gonna go huge center tank with a huge no
give me a huge center lifter do daddy
thingy we're gonna get big old bad ones
with in lots of symmetry modes like that
so we got high thrust and then we got
low thrust and I think working together
that's pretty good
I think together they're gonna be you
know pretty pretty stable
tailfin yeah I'll be good okay all right
we're good to go all right now before
this thing can even fall over cuz it
doesn't look too steady there looks a
little top-heavy there hey dancer
welcome back if that is you there we go
yeah we're going to space yeah
yeah overheat that doesn't sound good
but I mean what's the worst that could
happen right what's the worst that could
happen huh what happened
did we lose an engine think we lost an
engine yeah the whole rocket came off
well this isn't gonna make it into space
so let's just take all the SAS is
keeping us pretty stable I can't even I
can't even intentionally turn it that
hard it's very very stable huh I guess
having thrust more to the top of the
center of mass is good well lesson
learned let's just try to rock the sorry
dancer you're an experiment into failure
here oh oh what oh what what what oh
what Oh what
okay we're done I'm not gonna watch you
die we're done dad this went horribly
awry this went horribly awry so I'm
still learning I'm still learning one of
these days I'm gonna get this into space
but for now I'll accept failure funny
funny funny failure so thank you all so
much for watching click the annotation
for more videos I've done and as always
I will see you in the next video